with cobalt toxicity from bilateral hip implants 19 years ago, while in the process of hip revisions
to remove the cobalt, do you recommend anything to help with heavy metal detox? Systemically,
I think they meant. The thing is, if you have the implants in your body right now, you can't
do heavy metal detox, so let's rephrase that answer. If you have metal implants in your body,
that you're having issues with, so it is leaching that metal into your body, so therefore you're
having issues with it. And you use a heavy key later, so typically in order to pull metal out of
heavy metals out of your tissues, you would use a key later. Now, understand, I have labeled
that phase of detoxification as phase zero, so I don't think you have any business doing that
for a couple of reasons. Number one, if you still have the implants, you should not be doing any heavy
key laders. That's like if you have mercury fillings and you're going to do heavy key laders,
all you're going to be doing is pulling that possibly out of your teeth into your body. It's just
the foolishness. So you've got to not use heavy key laders. If you have a piece of metal in your body,
and you're trying to, and you're having a reaction to it, you have to get the metal removed,
and then you key late excess metal that is systemic in your body through key laders. But you don't
do chelation therapy, oral or IV chelation therapy, and tell you support of the other six phases of
detoxification. I could buy more information on our website on the seven phases of detoxification.
I've written a little short booklet on that. I have videos on that, and I have a complete course
of the seven phases of detoxification. Quite quickly, you have to support everything else because
if you're going to chelate it out of the tissue, you're pulling it out of the tissue. Where's it going?
It's going to the bloodstream. Where's it going from there? It's not going to the toilet. It's going
through your liver. So that your liver has to take it through phase one, two, and three in your liver,
get it placed into the bile. It travels from the bile down the bile ducts, stored in the gallbladder,
and then it's transported into the small intestine. Then it's transported through 30 feet of the
intestines and hopefully into the toilet. Now, those all consist of what I call phase one, two,
three, four, five, six, and you don't have any business of chelating things out into the blood
unless you support in all those other phases of detoxification first, or most likely, you're just
going to make yourself sicker. So, number one, if you still have the implants to answer this person's
question, you should not do any chelation. Once you get the implants removed and replaced with
something safer, then you could do chelation, but only after you've addressed those other six phases
of detoxification. If you could do this concurrently, but you've got to deal with those other six phases
of detoxification. If you're really interested in our courses, I think the detox courses,
$49 or something like that, go on that. It's a good $49 spent to understand those phases to support
those things. It doesn't have to be difficult. It doesn't have to be confusing, but I try to,
that's why I put the course together to help you understand that. I've just seen over 30 years
of doing this kind of stuff as seeing people get sick, doing a key later. While I'm doing this detox
application program, it can highlight heavy metals. My doctor put me on EDTA to pull out heavy metals
and I just got super, super sick. That's because your liver was congested. So, all you do is pull
about it with the EDTA, which actually works. You pull it out of the tissues, put it into the blood,
it had no room to get through the liver because the liver was already congested. So, it just got
deposited elsewhere, it circulated around, maybe worse across the blood barrier that's also damaged,
and you made yourself much worse. You want to do that. So, follow the seven phases of detoxification,
booklet or course, and that will be the way to go. But, in short, you do not do
chelation therapy at all, if you have the metal still in your body. So, that's just, you just can't
do that. So, you can support all the other six phases of detoxification. That can really help
a lot, but you can't, any chelation therapy, excuse me, while you got the metal in your body.